hello everyone and welcome to the last
game we'll be showing from round two of
the tata still chess tournament 2021
it's polish number one young [ __ ] of
duda versus uh swedish number one uh
niels axel grendelus and it's uh quite a
quite a brilliant attacking game
so without further ado let's check it
out and also let's check if
any of you are are in fact engines or or
maybe humans
uh you'll see what i mean by this so do
that with the white pieces
opens with c4 so the english opening is
on the board we have c5
and knight to f3 we have knight to c6
and b3 now
knight to c3 is the uh top move that is
played in this position b3 somewhat
rarer
uh white uh wants to find his dark
square bishop
as well as his light square bishop in in
the long run we have e5 by black and
bishop to b2 now with a double attack on
the e5 pawn we have d6 defending it and
knight to c3 now we have g6
uh grendelius also wants the fiance his
dark square bishop and the g3 now
this light square bishop will now also
be uh fianchetto so bishop to g7
bishop to g2 and now knight g to e7 here
uh grand ellis wants the castle he wants
to have nice support for
his uh f5 pawn and everything is going
nicely for black so now we have castles
castles and the now
d3 uh rook to b8 black wants to
start expanding on on the queen side
maybe with some a6 b5 moves in also it's
always a good idea to get the rook away
from this
a8 square if white finn cattle is the
bishop
so knight to e1 keeping an eye on that
d5 square as a white wants to get
this knight over to d5 so bishop to e6
and
knight the d5 it's not a problem and
this is a common theme if you are
a beginner uh it's always good to you
know get your knight in that central
square because
black either has to give up a bishop you
can never give up the knight because if
knight captures then black just loses a
piece so the knight is actually
perfectly fine there you don't really
have to worry about black capturing
so here queen to d7 black is preparing
this
bishop to h3 move also a common theme
when your opponent
castles king side i think it was the
bishop you wanna uh remove it because
then you've
removed the the light square bishop and
the pawns are on light square so there
are
holes on light squares which you can use
to your advantage
so knight to c2 the knight is now coming
to e3 and then uh or
adds additional support to the d5 knight
and now finally bishop to h3 so uh what
do you do here
queen to d2 you don't want to capture
and then uh
help the black queen to come to h3 or
maybe you do uh
duda doesn't want to do that we have
queen to d2 and now
bishop captures on g2 so this is all
very normal king captures and
f5 now and interestingly this has all
been played before
up until this point here do the place b4
which is not a new move
new move comes now uh c captures on b4
is what was played there is one game
uh from 2018 i think that was uh that
continues sea captures on b4 but uh here
dude uh granddale says
uh no that's a waste of time we need to
uh continue attacking on the king side
and he pushes f4
and it's only now as of move 15 that we
have a completely new game
so let's see how duda reacts to this
duda first captures on c5
b captures on c5 uh niels recaptures and
now e4 and here this is a
this is a really interesting moment
because how do you continue here with
white it doesn't seem like there are all
that many appealing moves so here
duda says all right we're going to close
up the center and we're going to deal
with
with the king side next uh there doesn't
seem to be all that many things black
can do to like
end the game immediately but there is
one very nice move and of course we all
see it
f3 followed by queen to h3 it doesn't
work just yet but it's um
you know it's a it's a working concept
so here f3 would
check king to h1 and now uh you don't
get anything by queen to h3 right away
because just rook to g1 you guard this
square and it's not a problem
if for example your rook was on f5 then
you could sacrifice the queen king
captures and rook to h5 checkmate but
it's not
so instead after king to h1 we have
knight to d4
just centralizing the knight and now
knight captures an e7
here uh grendelius could have uh first
captured on d5 if he didn't want to move
the queen from d7 because you kind of
want your queen on d7 but he says
it's not a problem i'm just going to
bring her back to d7 so captures
captures and now
knight the e3 the knight will now
be able to help out with the defense of
the king side and
queen back to d7 again eyeing that h3
square
we have bishop captures on d4 we have e
captures on d4
and now knight to d5 and this is now a
monster knight
uh which means that nothing can oppose
it
black doesn't have a light square bishop
this knight is on a light square and
if the knight wants to remain there for
the rest of the game the knight will
remain there for the rest of the game
that's how we
mostly how we define a monster knight
here on this channel and here
we have rook beat the e8 bringing the
rook into the game and this is a
crucial move for this position because
you want to get the rook the e5
h5 and then create some attacking
chances here
so rook to g1 uh and
now comes queen to g4 uh here if you go
rook to e5 right away
white might even consider g4 to take
away the the h4
uh the h5 square from the black rook so
here instead after rook to g1 we have
queen to g4
grendel who says nope you're not pushing
that g pawn
and uh here here is basically the
critical position of the game so here
uh if uh you can test if you're a
machine or if you're actually human uh
try and find the only good move for
white here the only move that pretty
much saves the game for white
while i give you a couple of seconds so
you know i try
try to figure out which move i'm talking
about
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations uh on spotting
uh the unspottable queen to a5
and this is just amazing to anyone who
found queen a5 you you sir truly are a
machine
uh because queen to a5 is so
counterintuitive you're getting attacked
on the king side and you bring your
queen all the way to the queen side but
now we're going to show
why this works because after rook to e5
of course with with the idea of bringing
the rook here
white first plays knights to f4 and now
the reason
why g5 doesn't work if you play g5 then
just queen to c7
and uh sorry queen to c7 and this is now
really crazy g
captures on f4 sorry my interface is
lagging a little bit
we're just going to have to refresh that
for a second there we go
so queen a5 rook to a5 and now like we
said knight to f4
and now the problem is g5 doesn't work
because of queen to c7
and here uh black white successfully
defended black has no way of continuing
the attack rook h5 is no longer an
option
and of course if you capture this then
white is completely winning the
black queen has to move and the white
delivers checkmate
or you have to give up the queen one of
those so the thing is
after this knight after this queen to a5
move
uh you're gonna play not g5 but rather
rook captures on f4 and this is how
white defends
g captures an f4 queen captures with the
threat of
rook h5 and then of course checkmate or
black white will have to lose some
serious material
now uh queen to c7 and that's it you've
defended and
black doesn't have a good way of
continuing this you can't go for this
because the queen hangs
and other than that you don't have much
for example if queen to h4
with the idea of rook h5 it doesn't help
you all that much because the queen
covers the square either way and also it
just loses material queen to b8 check
now you cannot block with the bishop
because the rook hangs and if you go
king to f7 then it's not a problem just
rook to g3 and uh white white
is no it's not white who's attacking if
rook to h5 just rook captures with
check again like we said the queen
covers the h2 square
it's not a problem but this was the
moment where
it could have gone well for duda uh well
not
you know in terms of not losing the game
but after queen to g4 duda played queen
to d1 he decided to
to defend differently but now it doesn't
really work rook to e5
knight to f4 everything the same like in
the previous line but now g5 by
gandalius and now
g5 definitely is an option uh because
uh well what do you do here you can't
really move the knight if you move the
knight again you give up the e6 square
for the rook and then the rook can get
into the game
for example if the knight moves let's
say knight back to d5
then you go rook to e6 and there's no
defending this is just a very ugly
position to play queen f1
rook to h6 and whatever you play here
it's just
not not good enough there are no no
moves here
uh whatever you play you run into the
exact same checkmate that we talked
about let's say rook b1
as we said there are no moves here queen
to h5
threatening checkmate and that's just it
uh nothing to be done here you have to
start
giving material and it's just all over
uh or you could play h3 but it doesn't
really help you just captures captures
and captures and it's a similar
checkmate because the g2 square is
covered
away from the white king so after g5
now uh this doesn't work so duda tries h
not h4 uh duda tries h3 kicks away the
queen
now queen back to d7 and now of course
while you could capture uh right away uh
not not an option first queen captures
uh uh on f3
because if you move the knight again
like we said queen captures on h3 is
checkmate so the knight unfortunately
has to remain there
so here queen captures an f3 by duda and
now comes rook to e7 again you don't
want to rush it with capturing for
example captures captures and
that's a that's a pretty mighty pawn
chain in the center white might the
double rooks here on the g
file black is still of course better but
you don't want to allow any counter
chances
so instead rook to e7 just adding
another defender to g7
and of course the knight still cannot
move rook to g2
we have queen to c7 and now comes queen
to h5
again uh it's interesting if you go
knight to d5 and go for an attack on the
black queen
black of course happily trades because
he also wins a piece so
now black is completely winning material
wise so after queen to c7 we have queen
to h5
finally on pinning and now of course you
have to capture the knight
otherwise the knight will move so g
captures on f4
g captures and now queen captures on f4
and now white is just
down down a piece and while you could
continue playing this
uh and of course the duda will you have
the open g file you have some attacking
chances
it's going to be very hard queen
captures on c5 was played and now queen
to h4
going after that h3 pawn so rook to g3
defending it
and now again you don't want to waste
time grabbing pawns because then you
just
help white mobilize his pieces so kink
the h8 just
unpinning and now rook 8 to g1 we have
b6 now kicking away the white queen
queen to d5 and now
queen to f4 and again uh what do you do
here
not not a lot of active moves for white
here uh f3 is one option but
it doesn't really help white all that
much white started pushing here c5
b captures on c5 queen captures and now
queen to e5
black offers a queen trade white of
course cannot accept this because the
end game is completely lost so queen to
c6
and now rook e to f7 doubling up on the
f-file
going after that pawn here rook to g5
attacking black's queen
queen to f4 and now even e5 white
finally started uh pushing his pass pawn
but now
queen captures an f2 we have queen to e4
and here comes rook to e7 and he was in
this position that young schuster duda
resigned the game
and niels grandelus is victorious here
and by winning this game nils emerges as
the
sole leader after round two we're not
going to be showing the standings we're
going to show the standings after round
three like we said
uh but yeah an excellent victory with
the black pieces against polish number
one young shisht of duda and here
you resign because you're just worse i
mean you're down a piece and you don't
really have anything
for example e6 you can just trade queens
queen f3 check
captures captures and not much to be
done here if king h2 defending the pawn
just recaptures
everything's falling apart for white uh
so
after rook to e7 duda resigned and uh a
brilliant victory for niels grendellis
we'll see how long he can keep up
this lead in the tournament maybe maybe
even forever we will see how it goes
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
steven torro mike waldner finn and jonah
janna solotar and chief arbiter lothar
schmidt
it's not actually the this gentleman as
he's no longer alive
uh unfortunately but uh you know a great
uh
uh great uh pay honor to you know to the
to the legend himself if you
if you watch the bobby fischer saga on
this channel or
some you know any other channel for that
matter and you know who lotta schmidt is
then you you are doing well if you
haven't i will even put a link to the
my entire bobby fisher saga in the
description below so you can uh
check up on it and you know uh learn of
this great legend
that is chief arbiter lotter schmidt uh
so yeah thank you everyone
for the contributions uh as usual uh you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and i will
see you soon
continuing the coverage of the tata
steel chess tournament checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day